i had actually kind of had grown jaded
with a television business a local news
business because
there had been a lot of corporate
consolidation and uh you know
there was less autonomy at the local
level
for reporters like myself and anchors to
pursue stories that
you know i felt like were really
important to our audience there were a
lot of
mandates from the corporate offices and
you know edicts from on high and we're
going to focus on this
and you know i think that's problematic
with our country right now where you
have
a lot less local news a lot less
investment in local news and you have
less coverage
of the places where the rubber really
meets the mo
road in our democracy and that's in your
county commission meetings your school
board meetings your city council
meetings
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host
of john bachman now on newsmax
john bachman welcome to the reuben
report dave great to be with you
i felt that i had to do that a little
more as a news anchor
because i'm with a news anchor did that
seem right to you well i appreciate it
because you know
when i have you on my show i always try
to do the reverse and try to be more
dave rubinesque
more free-flowing you know i i maybe i
should just unbutton the top collar
that's right we're on youtube right
maybe i'll unbox the jack and we can
relax a little bit right let's do it
let's settle in
calm down if you want to unfurl the hair
a little bit
whatever you want to do you're okay here
uh listen i am glad to have you on i
feel like you're the right guy to have
on
sort of just a little bit before
inauguration we are in
a seriously weird time and as i
as i often tell my audience i just have
this short list of people that are even
remotely sane right now and i kind of
put you on that list
for for the people that have no idea who
you are uh just give me a little bit of
a
a little bit of the john bachman's story
and then we'll talk about the news of
the day well i imagine that's most of
your audience
you know i'm kind of new to this
internet thing i'm a traditional uh
tv news anchor type i you know i worked
for
about 20 years in local news started as
an intern
at waga fox 5 in atlanta
and then went to augusta georgia the cbs
affiliate there w
uh ada and then moved down to west palm
beach florida because i wanted to
be kind of on the political fault lines
of american politics and of course west
palm beach palm beach county was one of
those
areas where you have you know a pretty
diverse
uh political population and uh turned
out to be everything i expected and more
you know i come to newsmax from that
perspective i had actually kind of
had grown jaded with a television
business a local news business
because uh there had been a lot of
corporate consolidation
and uh you know there was less autonomy
at the local level
for reporters like myself and anchors to
pursue stories that
you know i felt like were really
important to our audience there were a
lot of
mandates from the corporate offices and
you know edicts from on high and we're
going to focus on this
and you know i think that's problematic
um with our country right now where you
have
a lot less local news a lot less uh
investment in local news and you have
less coverage
of the places where the rubber really
meets the mo
road in our democracy and that's in your
county commission meetings your school
board meetings your city council
meetings
uh you know and we're seeing this right
now i think dave with the vaccine
rollout where you had a very successful
you know operation warp speed on the
federal level and then when those
resources whether it's vaccines or money
from fema when they get down on the
local level
you really see a breakdown and the
ability to execute
these types of national plans and you
know
and here i am you know i i worked so
hard this was always
kind of my goal to get to a place where
i had a national audience
but now now that we're here and you see
the you know the pandemic response and
you know the disparate response from you
know california and new york versus
florida and how it's affecting
you know the mental health of people and
you know you think about other things
too
uh in georgia or other states where you
had a complete breakdown of confidence
in the election system you realize that
this is really
where our focus needs to be now and so
as we kind of reposition ourselves here
uh looking ahead to the bide
administration
and of course keeping an eye on that we
have got to also
do a better job of introducing america
to
you know state houses and what's going
on at a local level
uh so that we can understand what's not
working in this country i mean this is
still a federalist system we have and
we're all fighting to protect that
and we still have unfortunately we still
have this kind of
laboratory of ideas when it comes to
different you know policies and
prescriptions for problems we have in
this country
and again we're seeing that with this
with this pandemic and completely
different approaches from cuomo
and gavin newsom versus ron desantis and
we know you know sometimes that doesn't
work and now
i'm sure a lot of people are looking at
the florida model and say
maybe florida man isn't so crazy so
that's kind of a winding narrative here
but you know
why i'm attracted to you dave and why i
have you on our show
is because this idea of free thought and
that's why i'm here at newsmax now
because this
provides me the platform to do the
things i couldn't do
as a traditional quote unquote news
anchor
it's interesting i asked you john
bachman 101 a little bit about your
history we talked about covid response
federalism
government television the whole thing so
before we go
any further you work for newsmax yes
isn't that some sort of far right crazy
extremist network john that's what they
tell me you know the funny thing is too
dave um
is it's all that you know of course in
some people's minds and at the same time
you know i'm a traitor for saying all
the way back in december and just trying
to tell the audience that yes
you know the bar is very high for joe
biden not to become president i think we
talked about this that
at a certain point it was like a space
shuttle that had launched into the sky
uh and if it didn't make it into space
into orbit it was gonna be some sort of
catastrophic explosion
that would prevent it and it never
happened i mean we're here now
and you know i think you know when
you're taking flak
from the extreme right as we are when
people calling me a traitor for calling
joe
biden the president-elect or from the
far left because
you know we just want to do something
simple as kerry the president of the
united states speech which i think we
were the only major network to do that
uh this week when the president was down
at the border i mean he's still the
president of the united states and his
words
still matter and nobody really wants to
do that
you know that's just you know what we
tried to do is kind of chart a different
path and provide information
that wasn't being provided for a lot of
people and that somehow dave
has become a radical idea do you find it
sort of tough to be a news anchor
in a time when not only is there
cable news obviously and sort of the
dying dinosaur of the
you know the big three cable news
channels but now there's a whole bunch
of other channels like newsmax then
there's like the gajillion people
on youtube and podcasts and everywhere
else that finding a niche that actually
makes sense that's still
true to who you are uh is is sort of
tough
just business-wise and everything else
yes i do i think it is tough in some
respects
i mean i think um you know there are
very few places that can provide
me this type of opportunity or other
great people we have that work for us i
mean
you know chris reddy our ceo really is a
believer in the idea of a big tent
and you know individuality and you know
the the
you know competition of ideas and
you know that's what he promotes and it
was in kind of a random way
that he and i met i know i talked about
my background as a tv news reporter i
remember one day specifically
i woke up was reading the newspaper the
palm beach post and i read
a little blurb there was a great
political reporter who no longer works
in local news he's gone on to do other
things his name is george bennett
he wrote about the fact that sarah palin
was going to a place called newsmax
to visit this was after the 2008
presidential election she was obviously
a lightning rod
and i wanted to go meet sarah palin i
was fascinated by her her story
her appeal to conservatives and so i
showed up at newsmax not knowing much
about newsmax and
i worked the parking lot met some of the
people who showed up to meet sarah palin
and asked them why they were interested
in her and they liked her outside her
philosophy
um and you know at that same time that's
when i met chris ruddy the ceo of
newsmax
and he and i struck up a conversation he
and i talked about a lot of things
i had expressed at that point kind of my
disillusionment with um
you know the local news business and he
gave me his business card and said hey
let's go to lunch
sometime and at that point i was
interested in
what he had to say about the the
business and you know long story short
that was
10 years ago and he had mentioned at
that lunch the idea of starting
a cable news network because he he felt
like there was a vast portion of america
that even with fox news and other
conservative outlets that were not being
reached
and so you know here we are all these
years later
to have this opportunity to be on your
show
to have this you know new audience find
us as an alternative and a compliment
you know to the spectrum of conservative
media that's available
is just really humbling is isn't that
actually the cool part that it's like
there are all these
networks popping up you know right
leaning or conservative leaning networks
and i don't sense that
although obviously at some level there's
competition there's only so many ad
dollars to go around or whatever
it might be but it's like there's the
blaze there's daily wire
there's news max there's more and more
there's independent guys there's the
whole thing and it's like everyone's
kind of helping everybody i go on
everybody's shows i'm happy to promote
everybody
and it's like man we just need more and
more let's if i find a new voice that's
good i'm like
man come with me with me on this
adventure i'm with you 100
dave and the way i kind of look at this
and uh forgive me because i have some
southeastern conference bias here you
know congratulations to alabama and
everything i'm a georgia
grad but i consider conservative media
almost like the sec like the elite of
the media
and you know you may be alabama and i'm
georgia here uh
but when it come we might compete in our
league when the when the time is right
when it really matters like on election
night
you know we're going to be in position
to really have the best ideas because we
compete with our ideas
and i think you know in the long term
you know you ask
you know people of a certain age are
more conservatives you know
at the later end of your lifespan than
the younger folks it's because
conservative ideas
eventually do win out over time when you
have the
advantage of perspective and longevity
and history to look back on you realize
that the things that got us here to
where we are as a country have worked
and most of those things whether it's
federalism
or you know checks and balances those
kind of old school ideas
it's really conservatives that have
continued to talk about those things and
really defend
those principles throughout history and
it's very exciting because we have those
things for another seven days
well i honestly think i mean this is
scary for a lot of folks here but
i'm reminded of many times in history
when we've talked about how bad things
could be i i try to take stock in the
fact that we do have the most divided
congress basically we've ever had
in our history um almost as evenly split
as it could be in the house and the
senate and for
somebody like kamala harris who is the
deciding vote
the tiebreaker in the senate she has an
enormous amount of responsibility
and i think and i hope that she will
weigh that responsibly because it's
going to be on her shoulders
you know they're talking about
eliminating electoral college now that's
their big thing
and does she really want that on their
record you know eliminating all the
history and all
the positive things that that has done
to thwart
uh the you know the tyranny of the
masses the things that could have
you know if it weren't for the electoral
college we you know slavery would have
existed probably much longer dave so
these are the things they want to tear
down we know it's kind of symbolic at
this point
and i'm really hopeful while at the same
time skeptical that they actually want
to do this stuff because they know
based on what happened like you know the
supreme court for example that there are
unintended consequences and it usually
comes back
to bite him in the ass yeah listen i i
i hope you're right i do hope you're
right but i actually
think they want to do absolutely
everything that they say they want to do
and the electoral college stuff the pack
and the court stuff
whether it's post impeachment of trump
like just
whatever crazy bananas things someone
puts up there
i think they want to do all of it i just
see do you see any reason to think is
there anything in the movement right now
that comes up as like a roadblock for
you that they're like oh well maybe
they'll turn around now i mean they are
seeing the cliff over there i mean maybe
that this one you think well
you know i i hope so i had mark halperin
on my show today
you know kind of looking at the public
opinion polling available on this
impeachment issue is pretty weak right
now but there are polls out there
that showed us the same thing as it
showed us last time when they were
talking about impeachment the country is
evenly divided on this
you know and i still believe in the
collective you know kind of
power of the individual of course but
you know the american public too and
there were a lot of promises made
about two thousand dollar stimulus
checks from the democrats
especially those who recently won those
seats in georgia
if they fail to deliver on that you know
i think there's going to be enormous
blowback
from this country again because they're
being disingenuous about their true
motives
and the american public is a lot smarter
than i think nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer and joe biden and kamala harris
give them credit for
and again and that's why i'm optimistic
still at the end of the day dave is
because we still have
you know 75 million people in this
country who appear
you know sane and you know which side
i'm talking about
and again i don't want to pretend like
i'm a partisan here but when you look
at the comparison it's a stark contrast
and it's it's it's con
it's hard for me uh to see how people
went the other way sometimes but again
that's just my opinion i guess i can say
that here
in this form no well i'm curious though
how do you balance that on a day-to-day
basis like when i do your show it's
pretty obvious to me that you're a
profes like you are a professional
newsman do you consider yourself a
traditional journalist still
no because it's obvious to me that you
have opinions and you're not afraid to
say them
but you are presenting news i think
there's almost an expectation now from
the audience not to give your opinion
but to be honest about where you're
coming from and i always talk about this
isn't not necessarily my opinion it's
more or less my perspective
you know giving people some insight on
where i'm coming from you know i grew up
in the deep south but my parents
are from the northeast i almost you know
i consider myself a first generation
southerner
you know even growing up in the 80s and
90s catholic in the deep south with
northern parents
you'd have friends and they'd be
somewhat skeptical of what
you know are you carpet back what's
going on here that type of thing um
but again you know it it it it's a
diverse kind of background to have
and a different way of thinking at
things and that's kind of just always
shaped my
perspective so but you know people
expect you to to kind of be honest
with them where you're coming from on
these things so i like to
say i do two things here i'm going to
lay out the facts for you and then i'm
going to tell you
why specifically we chose those set of
facts because
i have a limited time for my show so
there are only so many facts i can
provide in there
and there are other news outlets that
focus on other facts
but these are the facts that i think are
the most important facts and those facts
come
you know based on my history where i
grew up
what i believe the books i'm reading the
movies i'm watching and so
i do try to give the audience insight on
those things
so they have kind of perspective on
where my perspective is coming from and
that
you know i talk about this with my
college journalism professor all the
time
david huczynski who used to work at nbc
news he is
admittedly a liberal and we argue about
politics all the time
but when it comes to the practice of
journalism you know the rules are still
the same at the end of the day
trust your sources attrib you know give
attribution to where your information
comes from only choose sources
that are really trustworthy tell people
the truth
what has happened you know and don't
speculate too much and you stay within
those lines
it's not hard i mean it is hard it's
difficult but
you can do both dave give people the
facts be honest with him about what's
going to happen you know
don't be afraid to call him the
president-elect when you know it's going
to upset the audience because
they might be upset with you for a day
or two and some people might change
the channel but come january 20th when i
was honest with the audience about what
you know historically and
constitutionally
the limits were for what actually were
going to happen and that
you know linwood might not be right long
term when you're when you are right
you know they they gravitate back
towards you and they respect you
for being honest with them and you know
that's what you're able to do with your
audience
that is what i hope the internet still
provides you know you're still on
youtube
thank god for that um you know i think
you're about to cross 1.5 million
followers on youtube and
youtube would be nuts to take that
platform away from you
because it would it would really upset
or piss off i can say 1.5 million people
so
you know just like i have faith in the
overall population of the country you
know i have faith in those 1.5 million
people who follow
who follow you on youtube and that they
would pick up the phone or do something
to force youtube to make sure that you
still have this platform
yeah i hope you're right you know i'm
usually the optimist
on these interviews when i bring on
people who give me like uh oh
the whole world's going to hell in a
handbasket but you're giving me the
optimist approach here
do you think it's kind of funny when you
know like cnn for example
like none of their anchors not that they
ever really do interviews
but that if they did an interview i
don't think that wolf
blitzer or don lemon or jake tapper
or brian stelter or whatever the other
made up names are
pretend humans i don't think that they
would admit
the biases that you just admit there i
think they would say no we're calling
balls and strikes and it is what it is
even chris cuomo
the biggest clown in in cable news i
think he would say
no i'm not i'm not a democrat or a
republican i'm not left or right i'm a
news man
and it's that sort of fraudulent
nonsense that people can't stand
you know my kind of test for a news
anchor
i like to ask them how much time did you
spend out on the street as a reporter
how many
doors did you knock on you know how many
pairs of shoes did you ruin stepping
in things you shouldn't step in because
you know you're a reporter
and maybe you shouldn't have been there
um you know i i think like that's kind
of what's
missing a lot of times from our news
anchors
is they haven't talked to enough regular
people you know the the
emphasis in this business is on get to
the top as fast as you can
you know young and you know shiny
objects that type of thing
but i agree with you not that wolf blitz
was one of those guys is that they would
tell you
with a straight face that they are
giving you the facts and maybe that's
what they believe because they're in
that sphere
but i think the thing that's really
hurting the media industry today
is that it's hard for chris chromo to go
out and have a dinner with his family
and be a normal person or go to a
grocery store and buy groceries without
being
accosted you know and i don't agree with
a lot of chris cuomo says i don't know
if you saw that exchange with him and
don lemon
don lemon doesn't have a law degree but
don lemon schooled him the other night
on uh you know free speech it was kind
of interesting to see
but you know i worry not just about you
know our celebrity news people
or our celebrity lawmakers i you know i
worry about people being able to have
real live you know interactions with
humans and really find out from the guy
at the deli
or the shoe shine guy or the guy that
cut your hair how their life is impacted
and you know these news anchors most of
them don't really leave
leave live normal lives in chris cuomo's
defense he did leave the house when he
had kovid to get into the fight with the
uh
with the bicyclist at his uh like 20
million dollar mansion in the hamptons
so
it's not that he's not getting out there
come on now yes it's i mean it's it's
it's good work if you can get it
it it is you mentioned you're a child of
the 80s and 90s one of the reasons i
like doing your show is
you get all of my references if i make a
total recall reference
or a naked gun reference on your show
you actually understand it i can talk
about cobra kai on your show and you get
it when i make those references
on fox daytime sometimes they don't get
it they kind of nod but i know they
don't get it
give me your your your best 80s action
movie i'm really flipping the script on
youtube
well i'm gonna go top gun i mean you
know i know almost every single word
from that movie i saw it seven times in
the theater in the 1980s
seven times yeah i i wanted to be a top
gun pilot afterwards until i found out
that you have to be very smart
you know a lot smarter than you have to
be a news anchor to be a pilot um
but yeah it's a great movie um you know
and it was one of those things
and since we're on youtube i'll tell
this joke and hopefully i won't get in
trouble for saying this but
you know i remember sitting in the movie
theater with my dad
my best friend gil and his dad we we all
four of us and you know friend
actually gil had two brothers so we were
there as well
and i was with my dad and there's that
scene you know when they're in the
bathroom or they're in the bar right
and uh you know they're talking about oh
the list is long and distinguished right
kazansky and he goes yeah well so is my
johnson
and i leaned over to my dad and i said
dad what's a johnson
and he just laughed he just you can make
that sort of comment on youtube look how
free you are right now you've never been
happier than you are right
but it's a it's a you know i say that
though because it was like a simpler
time and i think nowadays
um you know and great in context it was
just a movie
right but nowadays you know your your
parent might get arrested for bringing
their kid to a movie
and being exposed to something like that
there's just so much judgment
and you know so a lot of times um they
make
this stuff a lot more provocative than
it is by trying to crack down on it
yeah well the outrage thing i mean it's
like that that's got to be a tough part
for you i mean one of the things you
know i'm doing this daily
direct to camera telling people what i
think about the world thing now
and one of the things that i i really
try to do i only do about three stories
a day because i don't want people
to feel like they're in that hamster
thing all the time
when you sit down with your producers or
your team in the morning to
to go through what you're going to talk
about i sense you don't want people in
that either but you have to give them
more stories as
a true news show how do you like what
are your processes to make sure you're
not going to make everybody completely
psychotic by by the end of listening to
you for an hour
well i mean you have the
responsibilities you know what you have
the compulsory stuff that you have to
cover the information i think that's
critically important but i
you know always try to find something to
differentiate myself and today
i didn't actually get it on the air i'm
going to try to do it you know at some
point this week but i'm fascinated
by this story about the death penalty um
you know because
you know growing up catholic you're
taught to you know respect
life uh from conception all the way to
natural death
but you know over time as a
libertarian-leaning uh
thinker kind of you know pursuer of
information
you read stories about the death penalty
and how many times people are released
from death row because dna has cleared
their names and we have this new case
now
or not a new case it's an old case but
the execution has been stayed this week
of this woman
uh you know this would be the first
federal execution of a female inmate in
70 years
and so you know not a lot of coverage on
that you know in in
writ large and so that's something that
i'm focusing on this week and you know
i try to look at our coverage across the
network maybe on our website as well
and some other conservative media and
say what do i think is is interesting
and maybe not getting the attention it
deserves and that is just an example of
one story this week
that my producer is like well really you
want to talk about that
because you know it's not necessarily
right in the bullseye
of conservative news topics to think
about but the issue of the death penalty
to approach from kind of a thought
experiment and does this really work
you know from a conservative standpoint
it costs more money innocent people have
proven to be killed
yes there is a natural human instinct to
one catharsis after something terrible
happens
but you know you talk to some of the
people who have actually lost family
members
and have witnessed the murder be
executed and they don't feel any
catharsis after the fact they feel the
hollowness and emptiness and they don't
get the closure
they deserve and i'm not saying it's
right or wrong or should we have the
death penalty or not
but when it comes to you know thinking
about things critically and is this
right do we agree with this it hasn't
happened in 70 years that
right there makes it newsworthy those
are the types of things that get my
brain going on
should we put this in the the show today
so that's just an instagram
a little look into that yeah i mean on
that one you know as a guy that's kind
of new
to the conservative thing it's like i
take the more libertarian approach that
you just laid out there i just don't
want to give the state that extra power
and we do know that they screw it up
sometimes
but i get it you know i've debated it
with shapiro and with prager and some
other
conservatives who are traditionally more
pro-death penalty and but
you know what we don't trust influences
of mine too dennis prager ben shapiro
michael knulls you
everybody there at the daily wire i mean
and in this like what you were saying
before
you know a lot of times when you are a
conservative or you know especially when
you are
you know as i was once a conservative
inside you know a
mainstream media newsroom you really do
need inspiration sometimes
because you think you're going crazy
when everybody else thinks the same way
you're like no i don't see it that way
you know you want to be the guy standing
up and saying wait wait wait wait wait
this this isn't right you know you and
all you guys over there have been huge
inspirations over the years for me
you know entering this space so hats off
to you guys
i was just going to let you continue for
a little while while you were talking
about what an inspiration
it's always easy when uh when trump over
the last couple months
especially right before the election was
was shining a lot of light on you guys
and
telling people you know watch newsmax
[ __ ] in the morning is crazy
watch newsmax they're doing good stuff
and then he'll point people to oan and
then the next day he hates this network
and suddenly he likes these guys
uh how sort of aware is everybody that
like oh
trump's watching now and we better
i don't know act accordingly ignore it
what oh i
everyone's very aware obviously and you
know you know sometimes
it's it's just kind of strange knowing
that they have uh
us on at the white house and that you
know again something you say might
actually matter
inside that building and that again
there are times i just
can't believe that's actually the case
now that said
you know we do try to make sure that we
do not become trump tv that's not the
objective here at newsmax
um you know the former mayor of new york
city ed koch had that saying that you
know if you agree with me 80
of the time great you know if you agree
with me 100 percent of the time
you need to get your head checked out
and you know no politician
is right 100 of the time and as i tell
people and
i try you know encourage my staff as
much as you may love donald trump and i
have to be reminded of this himself
because
myself because i you know really did
think the trump presidency could
be transformational um and consequential
and it has been
um and it you know it's disappointing
that there will not be another four
years because you think about all the
good things that happened
what could have been continued but again
you know you just have to really tell
people that once somebody once you
bubble in that bubble and choose
somebody
to represent you in elected office
they're not your friend anymore
it's not your sports team you don't
support them like that you gotta hold
him accountable
and we can compliment the things that
donald trump does right
and we can criticize the things that he
does wrong
you know it's the only way you can
really honestly consider yourself
you know a check on the powerful and if
you don't do it
eventually for somebody like donald
trump or be honest with his supporters
you don't really have
the moral authority or the credibility
to do it to joe biden and we've seen
that you know with other
people you have to find some place you
can agree with the opposition
but also disagree with your own side
in a weird way do you think that that'll
make your job a little bit easier
having a biden administration because
people will know okay you didn't want
biden
but now you can like sort of be more
openly critical like i gotcha you
weren't pulling punches but that it
that in a weird way conservatives are
almost set up to be
to be the against team you know
i mean they're making it kind of easy on
us if they're really going to pursue
this you know push to get rid of the
electoral college if they're really
going to try to pack the courts
if joe biden's not going to stand up and
stop the impeachment
then yeah i mean it does make our job
easy if they pursue these radical
policies
that most of america outside of you know
major metropolitan areas
don't support it is going to make our
job easier if they continue to call for
defunding the police
and we watch once great cities like los
angeles and philadelphia and new york
and portland oregon and atlanta continue
to decline and you know become places of
decay
it's going to make our jobs easier and
i'm not hopeful for that i definitely
want to see the best for america
but if they continue to pursue these
policies if they do what they tell us
they were going to do
during the campaign then i'm sad to say
that our jobs will be much easier
yeah god and as i said before i hate to
tell you i think they're going to do it
yeah i i just my take is just that
they're going to do it that they're
they're not there's just nothing too
crazy which is a very weird
a very weird thing again this is where i
come back to the american people
they're not going to let them do it i
hope i i was i was reading about this
today well what if what if big tech just
stops the american people from
letting them connect we can't that's the
thing i go on your show and talk about
this a lot
yeah you know the thing is is we existed
without big tech and i don't want to
diminish
the risk that this poses um and you know
you hear about things
like um email providers cracking down on
donald trump's ability to reach his
supporters through email
and radio networks telling you know
their radio host and i
just yesterday i was saying look they're
coming for us on big tech but there may
there may still be those other avenues
where conservatives used to reach
their audiences and i i am concerned
about that but
i do have faith in the american public
in bartow county georgia today i was
reading about
local elections officials there and the
county commissioners there
and they're doing a recount a hand
recount of all the ballots there
from the georgia senate runoffs not that
they need to it didn't qualify
you know the race was not within the
margin that they require the recount
but what they're doing is they're using
this as an opportunity to build
confidence and show the people who want
to participate that it was a legitimate
process
complete transparency and they're also
using it to train people
how to be poll watchers and how to
process the ballots next time around
so you know i gave that long monologue
last week when you were on my show about
the real fight is at the local level
getting involved
people rolling up their sleeves going to
the school board going to the county
commission becoming poll watchers
becoming poll workers
and you know i'm so encouraged to seeing
that happening and
again you have 1.5 million people that
can be
really mad if something happens to your
show
and you know we got to pick our battles
to make sure they can't do this to us
we got to hold our lawmakers accountable
because they pass these laws that
they're not willing to enforce
you know if they're not going to do that
get those laws off the books president
trump was right for trying to repeal
section 230.
you know it's a law from 1996 david can
you imagine
trying to use a computer from 1996 in
today's technological world
they need to get rid of this law it's
it's expired
are you saying my apple 2c i guess that
was that was probably 1986
did you have pork the game cork what was
it what that was
quark oh no i'm thinking cubert is the
guy jumping on that i know cubert who's
quark
quark was some game on my apple 2e i
think and there was winter olympics too
i loved that game do you
winter olympics was nice oh i remember i
definitely remember winter olympics i
had that on nintendo but
what about lemonade stand did you have
that maid stan was a great and speaking
of
the winter olympics in the 80s since how
great
were the winter olympics in the 80s when
you had the eastern bloc
and you like you know if you did if the
if the united states did not
beat the the eastern bloc and whether it
was downhill skiing or any sport it was
like oh what does this say about us as a
nation
you know i will tell you this i've said
this on my show a couple times i think
that
like if you think of rocky iv you know
against drago right he's fighting drago
in moscow
on christmas day we knew as americans
who our enemy was right it was russia
was the enemy now
now that's you don't want to live in a
perfectly polarized world but i think it
that thing where we were fighting the
russian empire we were america for
capitalism
they were for communism it was like that
was the thing and it sort of helped
define ourselves i actually think that
one of the reasons
we're so out of whack right now is we
don't know who our enemy is
we don't know if it's external or
internal we don't know
if the good guys or the good guys or the
bad guys the bad guys
did russia affect our election or hate
trump or help trump is
china like none of it makes sense so
people
often define themselves by what they're
against and we don't know what we're
against right now
i know and you think about that movie
you think about uh red dawn
or you think about there was this movie
called riskies remember that one
about a uh you know all the people that
used to defect and this is another thing
about you know sports is
you know people from cuba or russia or
eastern european countries that used to
defect
to the united states because we all
believed this was the best place for
freedom and now it feels like only half
of this country believes that this is a
place you should actually
defect to if you're an athlete but if
you're you know an immigrant they want
to open up the door
and let everybody in and it's just so
strange
to hear that it's a little odd that
nobody
leaves america although i think that may
be changing kind of soon right i mean if
it was that if it was as bad for all of
these years as they'd said
you'd think somebody would leave the
only people who leave are the are the
rich guys who put the money in the
cayman islands and disappear to the
galapagos islands
that's right they they've got someplace
else to go and
you know the people i love this list of
people
i'm leaving if donald trump wins of
course they never left i you know
love it or leave it really is it and it
you know this is where
i wish more americans you know actually
would travel
around the world and appreciate how
great it is to live
in this country still to this day how
much better we have it
than anywhere else i mean you know we
talk about big tech
cramping down on us and you know i was
just really repulsed
to see a chinese communist newspaper
saying oh
look what look what's happening in
america it's dangerous to crack down on
free speech i mean
they're signaling to their population
that america
the idea of america and freedom and
liberty you know life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
isn't real and the fact that that
doesn't get more coverage or you don't
have a universal response
uh from this country in fact you have
some news outlets actually unwillingly
you know are not unwillingly but
unknowingly taking money from the
chinese communist party and
you know propagating their propaganda uh
without knowing it
you know you would think to your point
that there would be more awareness
about how dangerous the enemy is and
that's china
yeah well as a sports guy it's like you
know you watch the mba
which i didn't i literally for the first
time in my life did not watch one minute
of one game this entire season
i'm in la the lakers won the
championship from what i understand but
i did not watch one minute of it
um but the way that the coaches and
players won't criticize china under
any circumstances and who was it it was
the like assistant gm of the rockets or
something that basically got
destroyed for he was the one guy that
said something anti-china
and yet steve kerr and greg popovich can
rail
all day long about how evil america is
and they're they're like
you know carrying them around on their
shoulders you know i did an interview
with dennis cantor the basketball player
for the celtics i think he's on the
celtics now i i do not follow the nba at
all
but you know he's a turkish dissident
and it dissonant we were talking about
the hagia sophia
again you know it used to be a secular
you know tourist landmark which was
converted into an
islamic mosque by erdogan as a you know
you know the virtue signaling of
the arab world i'm sorry of the muslim
world that's what he's doing there
and i asked him a question about look
this you of all people should appreciate
how dangerous it is to not be able to
speak out about this stuff
can you comment about what the nba and
their inability and i showed the video
of the people
and this was you know again offensive to
me that you had
fans in our nation's capital who wore
free hong kong t-shirts inside an nba
arena and they were not allowed to do so
they were escorted out of the arena and
it shows you
how china has been able to reach into
america and influence our lives
i don't understand how more people
aren't offended by that
yeah that was one of those moments that
i was just like how
really perverse is this like united
states of america for people that
haven't seen it they should
you can pause this video and and just
quickly search it on youtube
hong kong shirts at nba games if you can
find it dave i'm telling you
i have not we've done we've tried to do
subsequent stories
and that stuff is stripped off the
internet it's it's hard to find it so
you know that's again this is the what
we're up to is china
has control over youtube in this and i
guess maybe this will be cut i don't
know
yeah this very us just talking about
that they're right i guess
jokes i can probably say the dirty jokes
from top gun but i can't talk about
people wearing free hong kong t-shirts
in the nba
that's scary actually i didn't want to
tell you but i'll do a very newsman
thing i'm getting information in my ear
right now
uh they will not allow us youtube will
not allow us to
uh play that johnson joke that you made
okay
probably for the best for probably for
the best for my we can put a bleep or
something in there and you just tell
people
john bachman said a dirty joke one time
quoting a movie i'm not not my dirty
joke but
probably for the best dave thank you it
probably is for the best
yeah so everything sort of feels upside
down what what else are you interested
in beyond just like
the political stuff i love i love the
ocean
you know i live in florida i try to get
to the beach as much as possible i love
to fish
i love to surf um you know i love
catching you know something i've done
recently with my small kids i started
fishing with them a little bit
and as a parent
watching your young son release a fish
into the water something that i did with
my dad
something that my dad did with his
grandfather and his grandfather did with
his father and et cetera you know this
is a
family tradition that to me uh
is the ultimate right there so the
outdoors
um being with my family and then food i
think we share that in common
food is the other thing i basically you
know live my life from meal to meal
i love to cook i'm greatly inspired by
your you know your steaks that you cook
i i i have so many questions for you on
that front
uh are you a version guy i mean we can
talk about that some other time
but um yeah those are the things i'm
interested in my family
um so you're a florida guy wait wait
let's pause for a second we'll get to
family in a sec but you're a florida guy
the day i got to florida a couple weeks
ago i think you were leaving
you were headed to georgia i think uh
florida uh
it's free you're living in a free state
i live in a not
free state that's got to be very
exciting for you you know and i don't
take it for granted in fact you know
talking to you and talking to so many
people who are down here
for the turning point usa student action
summit
from all over the country and you know
they had an ability to get out and do
something normal
you know for just a few minutes and you
really see
and you know our conversation about this
how important that is to your life uh
just you know there is a almost human
right to sit down at a table and break
bread
with someone you love or a friend or a
you know business
you know colleague something like that
have somebody bring you the food
you know pay a little bit more money for
it and then take it away and you don't
have to clean it up i mean that
is a beautiful view it's a beautiful
thing and i'll never take it for granted
um you know considering that governor
ron desantis made
uh the very strong and bold decision to
keep this state open
and he is you know a hero you know for
to a lot of people for doing that
because uh mentally
florida seems to be the most sane place
in the country right now if you
can believe it would you have ever
thought that the state went that was
known for florida man you know people
wrestling wrestling alligators with
cigars in their mouths while saving the
dog
a very impressive guy by the way who
should probably get into politics that
florida would go from you know that to
like having the governor that you know
pretty much every sane person now wants
to be the president
well i i think a lot of people under
underestimate florida man it gets a bad
rap
obviously for all the criminality but i
mean there there is something called a
florida crack i've always loved florida
for the record
well there's something called a florida
cracker right and it and it's not a
derogatory term it's a term for a cowboy
florida actually has one of the oldest
and largest continually operating cattle
herds
in the country if you can believe it
they use whips but these are the old
florida pioneer prospectors it is a real
hardy type and they are very
uh you know useful and i think that is
kind of the underlying spirit of florida
you have a lot of diversity obviously
and that breeds competition
of ideas you know you've got strong
family values because of all
the latino influence down here as well
and florida has kind of reached a
maturation point going from
you know a retirement state to now
really a fully functioning state
and i think that's what you're seeing
reflected here uh and don't knock
florida man
there's a lot of uh great florida men
out here uh that
no no i listen you so you saw my tweets
i was like i hadn't been that happy in a
long time i mean the state was open
people were smiling you know everyone i
see here is in a mask every not that i
see anyone because everything's closed
anyway
i walk my dog people pull their dogs
across the other way the dogs are
starting
i'm not kidding you the dogs are
starting to go crazy here well the dog
because they can't be around other dogs
dogs can pick up on human behavior and
they know i mean that's
i think that's an excellent point if if
your owner is freaking out the dog's
gonna be freaking out too so i'm sure
that's a real thing
i always say you know there's no bad
dogs there's just bad people
right like it's like every time someone
i'm walking the dog and then someone
pulls the dog oh he's not friendly
i'm like well it's not really the dog
you know as you just yanked the dog and
like freaking
choked it and everything else um do you
sense
that uh if we get through inauguration
that the rest of the
states will start opening even even
andrew cuomo has now started hinting
that he might open
new york basically i mean he's not
really admitting it but it's a basic
complete admission that his policies
have been awful yeah i mean i think
democrats like andrew cuomo are learning
the limitations of their ability to
outsource the blame
to the federal government uh because
yeah you know i've started to take a
closer look at this
and operation warp speed is a miracle
the fact
that you know less than a year after we
have a completely new virus
you can have a vaccine but when you get
down to the local level
the the rollout of the vaccines has been
disastrous and andrew cuomo is now
trying to cover for that
he wanted to make it available to
frontline workers line workers didn't
want it
and you know and so they had doses of
the vaccine
going bad outside of the freezer and now
i think he's just trying
flailing to save himself and he can't
blame joe biden
a week from now so you know he's got to
do something and his state
is dying and you know i would hope
for your sake and for everybody out
there in california that gavin newsom
sees the writing on the wall and you
know follow suit
i think you were the first guy was it
you that were the first guy to ask me if
i was going to run for governor
i joked about it on your show and then i
went to you then i went to
you must have tweeted something that
gave me that idea because uh you know
i'm i'm pulling for you to come over
here dave and hang out with us
i literally joked about it on twitter
then you asked me about it on your show
next thing you know i'm in florida and
everybody everywhere and they asked me
about it on fox
and uh yes i think my future would be
much happier in florida
than as the governor of california i
think that's probably fair to say yeah
you know i i we need guys like you not
in politics right because if you're in
politics and you can't comment on
politics we need
you know and everything for some reason
people always ask me if i'm going to run
for office and i'm like
absolutely not i have it's a
sherman-esque answer
i would never ever run for office i like
criticizing office holders too much
yeah exactly well hey listen trump ran
for office and criticized it
so well i don't think we should ever i
mean trump is like
you know one of a kind and you know for
all he has done to change the republican
party
for for anyone who tries to recreate
that
i think it's going to be just a fool's
errand because
he's a one-of-a-kind historical figure
and it's going to take a long time i
think for any of us to really understand
what we just experienced over the last
four years
john bachman i feel i should give you
one more opportunity to make an 80s
reference
um favorite comedy somewhere between 85
and 95. how about that
there's a very obvious answer to me uh
ghostbusters
does that count well goonies suppose
is that ghostbusters but goonies not in
terms of
funny do you think is funny no goonies
is funny
there's some funny moments but that's
not pure funny ghostbusters baseballs
ghostbusters is funnier
space balls could be in there i mean to
me i think i mentioned it earlier naked
gun to me
okay 19 it's perfection it's leslie
nielsen
perfection uh like it's it's airplane at
its peak basically
um but interesting goonies
yes you know i remember these you know i
just recently watched goonies
with my kids over the holiday break um
and i remember going to see goonies with
my grandmother in the movie theater
and she did not like goonies and after
watching it with my kids i realized
maybe this shouldn't be pg pg i
you know different there were some sex
strategies from that from the movies
back in the 80s
and what's pg now i don't know if that
would fly but anyway it was i think it
was cooler back then
you had a better relationship with your
parents they could explain things to you
and you didn't have stuff
i really worry about the kids today
because they're just bombarded with
stuff
on the internet it's hard for them to
avoid the things we were able to avoid
as kids
it's hard for them to maintain their
innocence
bachmann i hope you enjoyed loosening
the tie
go all the way down yeah and speaking
freely
on the interweb i will see you soon i
assume on your show and
eventually i will i will grill a steak
for you
in florida i will sear the hell of a
steak
for you what's your cut by the way
what's your preferred cut of steak dave
i've been loving these tomahawks lately
you know just like the fred flintstone
style tomahawk i did like a four
pound one the other day now i know that
in california
technically you're not a lot of people
at your house and i don't want to say
too much
but let's just say it was eat you know
people ate it i don't want to get into
the numbers in case gavin's watching
um but man it was just perfection
we'll just say it like this none of it
was wasted right and they they can agree
with that hopefully dave i appreciate it
thanks so much john bachman
the host of john bachman now on newsmax
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell